Esta é uma das coisas que vamos comer
hoje sopa de galinha
isto não tem nada bom Espero
ingredientes todos em chinês
temos salgados temos doces temos miojo
temos bolacha muita coisa então já
deixei o vosso like pessoal e bora lá
vamos avaliar também as comidas Mas em
vez de ser de 0 a 10 Vamos inventar aqui
um termômetro diferente as piores
comidas vão ser lixo assim mas está o do
aba para a minha tia ali se for uma
comida mais ou menos é até que é bom
acima disso é gostoso e no topo lá em
cima se for delicioso é comida dos
Deuses sou pé de galinha fica mais para
o fim vocês estão a ouvir para a
primeira experiência gastronomia
asiática de hoje vamos comer bolacha de
Pokémon o que é isto meu tem muito
ingrediente aqui em chinês eu não sei o
sabor disto mas a embalagem tá perfeita
ou não é o Pikachu mas o isto aqui fogo
esqueci meu nome acho que este é o
torchic é sorte e este não faço ideia
isto deve ser um dos novos Ok mas o que
temos aqui é uma waffle uma bolacha Bora
lá abrir
já sentiu o cheirinho isso daquilo que
tem prêmios supostamente porque eu já vi
aqui uma coisinha dentro
um cartão
Que vela surpresa Bora vamos então a
nossa bolacha
chocolate chocolate
meus amigos
antes de conclusões precipitadas
muito crocante e o recheio é mauzinho
Olha isso
nem sei que Pokémon é este Mas vem com
Estica e a nossa bolacha de Pokémon está
no nível gostoso é muito boa essa
bolacha meu Deus do céu para uma coisa
superprossada super seca embalada há
mais de 20 anos ótimo gostoso esta eu
vou voltar a comprar só a pena é fazer
este lixo todo enfim próximo produto são
caramelos de coca-cola uau a origem
Japão
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Temos mesmo só dois sabores temos o azul
e o vermelho e todas as embalagens tem
um personagem diferente Ok vamos começar
pelo azul
já comi muita coisa assim parecida
[Música]
é meio estranho eu não quero mentir mas
acho que este outro coca-cola vamos ao
vermelho este aqui é o do Luigi Ah não
eu acho que esse aqui
eu estou coca-cola
definitivamente o vermelho de coca-cola
então o azul é de quê mas estes também
japonês eu não entendo não faço ideia e
este doce do Mário vai ficar no até que
é bom não é tão gostoso assim porque a
consistência é meio estranha mas também
não é mau então é até que é bom temos
aqui uma bolachinha eu pelo menos acho
que é uma bolacha um cereal não sei mas
é do Tinker e eu comprei para conter
isso E também porque eu acho que vem com
um brinde aqui tem aqui uns
colecionáveis Tem um aqui este deve ser
um raro né aqui os ingredientes ó notas
que que é bastante saudável né ou então
aqui em cima Vamos abrir eu acho que é
por aqui Ok o que é que nós temos aqui
um pacotinho
e bom Aqui está o resto dos nossos
cereais eu acho que estão aqui todos
Vamos provar
não pode ser verdade
tem umas dicas aqui ainda já vamos ver
chama o termômetro isto conseguiu
atingir o sabor dos Deuses Que bom ajuda
é muito bom é muito bom imagine um
choque mas mil vezes melhor é isso que
sabe é crocante por dentro é bem macio
desfaz na boca qual é o brinde que vem
aqui dentro ok
Não faço ideia do que isto é só comprei
Ok eu confesso eu na verdade eu só
comprei isto porque tinha a Peppa Pig Ok
tinha várias cores achei a embalagem
fofa
este aqui sabe a banana pessoal isto é
muito bom
ele literalmente uma gelatina melhores
gelatinas
se os outros sabores forem tão bons como
estes aqui
eu acho que vai para o gostoso Vamos
experimentar o azul embalagem Azul mas
as Gelatina é branca eu vou estar que é
de coco
vai ser de morango vamos lá Peppa Pig
não desiludas
agora que estou a pensar isto sabe tudo
muito ao mesmo
este entra no gostoso é muito bom ok não
é dos Deuses porque a consistência não é
assim tão boa Mas sabe muito bem e é
apenas uma gelatina
muito bom Agora sim pessoal preparem-se
porque vamos ao Carro Chefe aqui das
comidas asiáticas e vamos chamar o trio
Implacável de Naruto Vejam Só o que é
que temos aqui pessoal Nunes do Naruto
eu confesso que eu só comprei mesmo
porque tinha as personagens Ok vamos
começar então com o nosso amigo Kakashi
que é um dos meus personagens favoritos
aqui temos os dois dele tem ovo alga e
alguns documentos eu não sei se isto vem
aqui dentro Okay nós temos aqueles
ingredientes tudo em chinês ou japonês a
tabela nutricional Ok eu acho que aqui é
o indicativo do sal Este último que está
aqui tem 285% do sal recomendado que nós
deveríamos consumir diariamente Ok isto
ultrapassa de longe a quantidade que nós
devemos consumir diariamente ah este
deve ser o os dados de carbono 51 %
visto que é novo a sua idade então ya
Isto é um pouquinho tóxico para essa
luta mas vamos provar aqui hoje pessoal
não toca a caixa mudas de quem mais ou
menos do nosso amigo é um grande
personagem também este camarão com
certeza vamos ver aqui a tabela tem 295
de sal e temos aqueles números do nosso
amigo Jiraya ok ele tem algas tem
salsicha sei lá tem ovo também podemos
ver a quantidade de sal 170% da
quantidade recomendada diária ok também
ultrapassa bem mas já é bem menor em
relação aos outros Okay Bora lá Abrir
pessoal Ok temos aqui os nudes
inteirinhos bem bonito um molho Não faço
ideia esse sistema ou não mas não tem
Muito bom aspeto temos molho Cebolinha e
sementes vamos já abrir os restantes
pessoal eu vou deixar aqui em cima só
para não me confundir
eles têm mais mortes tem dois tipos de
mods aqui dentro é diferente
reparem que vem uma pasta meio estranha
aqui bora lá então preparar os nossos
[Música]
primeiro começar então pelos noodles do
Sasuke ficou com esta consistência assim
mais parecida uma sopa porque eu até
gosto de ter bastante água que é para
depois beber com o molho
realmente sabe camarão tem um toque
muito bom a camarão não é nada picante
eu estava à espera que fosse picante e
este está no até que é bom esta é
daquelas refeições que não é nada de
extraordinário também não é podre faz
bastante rápido até que é bom encaixa
perfeitamente Aí vamos então
este Com certeza é picante
eu não sou muito fã de picante
mas ó é um picante levezinho passa bem
tranquilo
este nota-se que tem assim um frango a
puxar o caril
é bom é bom definitivamente
se a minha tia este aqui está no mesmo
nível do cu do Sasuke Ok mas como eu não
sou apreciador de picante eu oferecia
esta minha tia definitivamente Este é o
do nosso amigo Kakashi Ok teve que ser
aqui numa embalagem menor porque eu só
tinha aqui esta disponível
o meu Deus
meus amigos os nudes do Kakashi estão no
nível
gostoso é muito bom tem um travezinho é
sei lá o quê Eu nem sei explicar isto
não sabe frango isto não sabem nada mas
é muito bom super É de longe estes dois
sopa de galinha reparem bem pessoal eu
tenho aqui uma sopa de galinha
completamente embalada tem aqui as
instruções com rodelas de qualquer coisa
tem tipo espetada de salsicha com alguma
depois colocar na água juntamente com os
pózinhos Ah e esperar fazer sopa eu acho
que é isso Pelo que eu entendi é isso
primeiro ingrediente Não faço ideia isto
vem embalado
num alumínio qualquer é bem duro que tá
aqui dentro
estou com óleo aqui que nos gera aqui
dentro deve estar todo o óleo todo o sal
tudo aqui dentro isto deve ser o que dá
magia à sopa tenho certeza mas o que é
calma é só isto eu fui enganado vem
também sementes de César não vai mais
nada pessoal eu jurava eu jurava que
vinha com estas coisas todas que tinha
com o frango tinha com a pata galinha e
o que é que nós temos aqui apenas três
embalagens César um óleo estranho e
outra coisa estranha aqui dentro
Você quer uma espécie de pó deve ser
como se fosse o equivalente ao nosso
caldo que nós né tipo uma calda em pó
que juntamente com installer e
juntamente com as sementes de César vão
fazer todo um caldo e só e depois é que
nós colocamos a carne em Espeto os
legumes e tudo o que eu queira talvez eu
deixei esta sopa para um Tik Tok ou
assim porque eu tinha de comprar os
palitinhos o dinheiro de comprar pata de
galinha é carne pepino tem muita coisa
aqui então para fazer realmente esta
sopa em condições eu tinha que ter
aqueles ingredientes e não tem então
talvez eu deixei isto para um Tik Tok
mas já valeu a pena pessoal Apesar de eu
me sentir aqui um pouquinho enganado mas
eu vou fazer esta sopa Ok sigam lá no
meu Tik Tok e é isso Pessoal espero que
tenham gostado aqui deste vídeo deixem
muito like o canal vai voltar ao ativo
Ok então inscrevam-se aí se não forem
inscritos e já que estão aqui assistam
também este vídeo que está muito bom
pessoal e é isso fiquem bem até a
próxima
[Música]